James Balog photographs disappearing glaciers in the most remote regions of the planet.
There's this transition from, you know, having this shape...
...and having a reality to going away....
...somewhere in there in that boundary between life and death,...
...it's where the story will be.
That story is in the Extreme Ice Survey,...
...a project that Balog founded and has directed since 2006.
His idea was to install cameras on glaciers...
...in Greenland, Iceland, Alaska, and the Rocky Mountains...
...and shoot pictures remotely during daylight hours.
That adds up to about 4500 pictures a year for each camera.
Balog says from the very first downloads, he was stunned by what he saw,...
...especially when played back as continuous video.
Your jaw drops sometimes, you go, "You mean that happened?"
"In the past two months, that happened during that one week? You gotta be kidding."
"How is this possible?"
And so just in general,...
...this rate of landscape evolution, of these huge features that you consider to be,...
...monumental, powerful, enduring, immortal parts of the landscape,...
...when you see them disappearing in a very short period of time,...
...it really alters your sense of time.